why does it have duration what does time
have direction
well time doesn't have direction because
you know one way sign has direction you
know you've seen a one-way sign on the
street and you say oh it's got ad race
facing that way or you have a sign that
says the city of New York is in that
direction
and we all understand that's a direction
why because there's a sign that points
in one direction and I can take a needle
and say look it's pointing in a certain
direction and you can understand it
because the needle is a physical object
now what do we do with time well what
can I show you what direction does time
have does it float in that direction in
the other direction which way does time
flow or point or which way is it
oriented yeah maybe it goes up or always
no down you know I mean I don't know
which way time goes because time is not
a physical object so it's irrational to
talk about direction of time and
mathematicians use the word for word but
for word is not a direction and I can
prove that very easily to you and I'll
prove it this is a proof okay so please
take my word for it your forward who's
facing me is different than my four
which is facing you so whose forward is
correct here I mean we all have our own
forwards right and the Chinese are on
the other side of the planet therefore
was a little different than our forward
and this is the problem the problem is
that we can't talk about the four
Direction forward as being a direction
it's not forward is not a direction okay
what is the direction right direction is
if you well a direction I do define that
do I know the direction no no it's not
because again forward is whose direction
yeah there's many forwards direction
okay okay but you can do it in terms
about an object like if a chair is
moving forward you say what is the
reaction of the chair yeah but how do
you do that with time I mean what do you
mean by forward direction of time and
against when you when you get concepts
that's when it becomes the wording
becomes blurry you can't give direction
to a concept you can't say love is going
up yeah in other words what I was trying
to say is that a forward is not a
direction when you use a concept when
you use an object like table you're
pushing and you're saying or the car is
going for when you say what is the
direction of the car but it's moving
forward my hand is now moving in the
rection forward and again I have a you
have to clarify what that direction is
because again your forward is different
than my forwards so you know direction
of movement and yeah but right but then
your movement you need an object but now
for time you can't talk about the
direction of time but you can move a
bucket you can talk about you know a
person moving but moving not through
time or in the direction of time or in
the direction of the future because
there is no such direction it's not the
direction as I see it is a point in the
distance like the moon you know I'm
trying to get to the moon so to me going
to the moon is the direction in which
I'm going I'm saying that's where I'm
going
that's the direction in which I'm going
to that object over there
yeah but how do you do this with the
concept it's like saying I'm going to
move in the direction of information and
what does that mean or the information
moves in a given direction what does
what does that mean objects have
location and concepts right so you can
assign a direction to or from in the
case of to or from an object but you
can't really assign the direction to
something that has no location yeah yeah
in fact uh there's my first action item
I'm not sure I've ever defined the word
direction and never found the need for
you I think but I'll have to look
through my notes I'm not sure now so uh
my son stumped me on the first one okay
yeah that's his job his job is to make
me look ridiculous year one zero yeah
I'm not sure about direction I I think I
do find it but I'm not not quite sure
yeah okay folks there will be a little
bit of out of focus which we can't fix
right now I have no idea what we're not
a focus okay
okay anyways I'm gonna start with where
we left off yesterday we had three three
issues brought up yesterday one was
about life the other one was about
entropy and I'll be addressing those
issues in the next couple days today I
wanted to address the third one which
was really the first one that was
mentioned which was the issue of
direction
what is direction and whether forward is
a direction ok and let me start with how
the question started and I think was put
by Thomas and/or he clarified I guess
that's what he did he clarified that in
wge oh man I can't I have no idea why he
goes out of focus you can see the sign
well right the sign sign comes out right
but I come out wrong anyways he said
that in why God does exist the book he
thought that he found this definition in
the book and it says direction of course
over which something moves or points I
checked today and there is no definition
of direction in all of why God doesn't
exist that's the definition on
on dictionary.com yeah I would think
that's of course always something or
someone moves yeah
that's not my definition in fact it
turns out that I do have a definition
but it's not in the book it's in the
website and I'll get to that in a minute
first I want to put up here let me take
this one out let's see if we can put the
formal definition that we have today so
that we can get this started and the
first one I want to take out rub it out
because it's got nothing to do with
physics it's really a philosophical
issue but it's the definition I found is
a line of thought or action or a
tendency or inclination the direction it
gives that example the direction of
contemporary thought so that's an
abstract definition of direction that's
that's not likely saying what direction
is Hollywood yeah what direction is the
country going now anything so so we're
not referring to that we're referring to
physical direction okay
and so for objects when we're dealing
with physics
the formal definition in fact it comes
the first thing that I found was what
does Direction mean it comes from French
word and that means arranging in line or
in a line straightening and the formal
definition you'll find is the line along
which anything lies faces moves etc with
reference to the point or region and
toward which it is directed Direction
directed and it gives an example the
storm moved in a northerly direction
okay so what does this give us it tells
us one thing it means if you read there
between the lines you'll find you
need a target okay let me read that
again says with reference to the point
or region toward which is directed so
you do need a target okay for the word
direction and I'm gonna disagree with
part of this definition and it's in the
word moves
why because direction I'm gonna argue is
a static concept like if I'm facing
north yeah you can talk about facing
pointing but not about moving okay okay
so let's go with the definition that
I've got here so hard uh get these
things sometimes this is the one I have
in I don't have a definition and why God
doesn't exist but I do have this
statement I say direction for it's part
is conceptually made quotations they're
of a single piece okay keep that in mind
and I say that is it is continues it's
made of a single piece and it's
continues okay conceptually that's
that's what we mean by direction in
physics it is considered irrational to
attempt to chop direction to points or
numbers as they do in math you don't
chop Direction into pieces and you don't
segment it okay magnitude belongs
exclusively to mathematics the direction
belongs exclusively to physics the
magnitude of mathematics is
irreconcilable with the direction of
physics because magnitude is a segmented
concept it's how many dots we have in a
row or what is my duty yeah magnitude
you're talking about numbers so you're
talking about number five the number six
it could be followed by units but the
point is there we're talking about
number lines we're not talking about see
this all comes with in relation to the
word dimension the word coordinate and a
word vector that's what we're that's
what's behind all this that's the
context so we're saying what is
dimension well we say that a dimension
has only two properties and that's
direction and orthogonality you need no
numbers for what a while what I just
said all you need these are qualitative
concepts so you say what is the
dimension in has direction and
orthogonality with respect to the other
two dimensions and the same for
coordinates by the way and I'll get two
vectors in a second but the point here
is I just want to get this thought
through this is the only thing that I
mentioned essentially with respect to
direction in why God doesn't exist in
the book and that is that it's not a
segmented concept you cannot chop
direction in half it makes no sense
direction is made of a single piece and
it's continues so it's not chopped in
two parts and so we have a problem when
the mathematicians say you know we have
a dimension which has two properties and
one of them is magnitude and the other
one is direction those two concepts are
irreconcilable I have a question about
huh yeah so if you ask for directions
like the normal direction every day we
ask for the directions to so-and-so
Street when someone says go north 50
steps the north part is a direction and
the 50 steps part is the magnitude and
not even that is correct
what's wrong is north is not a physical
object and I'm saying in order for you
to have direction you need a physical
object so you now get that into that in
a minute I mean that person didn't give
any didn't give a direction not a
scientific one it's an ordinary speech
and again we're gonna contrast here
ordinary speech versus scientific
language if we want to be say you see
this all starts here and maybe that
should have been my introduction when
you're starting physics when you're
gonna do science you you're gonna need
to define the fundamental words the ones
that you're gonna need to create your
foundation of physics
and you know one of those first words is
object you can't do physics without an
object another one is location you're
gonna need location you're gonna need to
know what direction what a distance is
between two objects you have to define
these crucial words because otherwise
anything you say beyond that is going to
be a problem you're gonna be founding
your whole theory your whole explanation
on quicksand you know you don't have
solid foundations like in a building you
build it you know in the mud well the
first mud slide there goes your building
why because you didn't put the proper
foundations underneath it and the same
thing is for physics and science but
specifically physics you need to define
these words in order to do physics and
one of them is direction it is direction
and the problem that you run into again
is when you apply these concepts to
dimension coordinates and vectors and
you haven't defined what direction
really is okay and and then you say well
you know a dimension has direction and
magnitude and that's what it doesn't
have because you can't have magnitude
with direction direction with magnitude
they're they're contrary concepts you
can have direction and orthogonality but
you cannot have direction and magnitude
which is what these people have this is
how these people define dimension okay
and so let's get to that next point here
which is why can't you have direction
and magnitude because magnitude is a
chopped-up concept what you're doing to
direction by including in that line
you're including magnitude you're
chopping up that dimension that
direction I'm sorry direction oh what's
the fun with it well you can't because
Direction camp each other just said you
can't chop direction in half you can't
chop it into pieces what problems do you
run
if you do it's that directions made of a
single piece that's why we have to
define what direction is before we can
go in there and say look we're gonna mix
it with with magnitude let's get the
concepts right before we mix them
because it's easy to say well you know a
dimension has to two properties
direction and magnitude and you said
well did you think about that deep
enough to make sure that you can
reconcile these two concepts what I'm
saying you cannot and I'm gonna get into
that so hopefully I'll answer the
question in eventually but what I'm
saying is we cannot reconcile direction
with with magnitude
what is a segmented concept the other
one is a continuous concept made of a
single piece okay okay so here I have
okay okay that's the one I just did
they're so difficult to find here
sometimes and I get what a couple of the
problems that I see with direction as we
have it now direction is a concept and a
concept invokes two objects you do
what's happened the blurriness factors
but yeah I don't know the direction is a
concept and as I defined the word
concept you concept requires two objects
okay
it's a relation between two objects
that's that's what a concept is
Direction involves a starting point and
an end point the important part here is
the end point and that's what we forget
especially when we get into the word for
word I'm gonna get that it into that in
a second and then direction is a static
concept okay it's not something that is
in motion
and why do I raise that issue I raise
that issue because in physics we have
the word vector and vector is a dynamic
concept in fact here's the definition in
the Wikipedia one of the definitions is
a concept characterized by magnitude and
direction okay and it says immediately
after that a vector is what is needed to
carry quotations carry the point A to
point B to the point B okay so you're
moving something from A to B that's what
a vector is and it comes from the Latin
word vector meaning carrier so we're
talking about motion vector is motion
dimension and coordinates are static
concept but vector is a dynamic concept
and again we have a problem because you
can't reconcile a dynamic concept like
vector with a static concept such as
directions
now we're used to saying in ordinary
speech yeah drive in the direction of
blah blah blah blah blah whatever comes
after that right and and we all
understand then we say okay that sounds
rational it's not rational for the
purposes of physics of rational physics
you cannot say go to this concept go to
the north if you're gonna move you're
gonna move to the moon towards the moon
or you're gonna move towards the tree
you move towards an object you don't
move towards a concept such as west or
north or you know towards love why not
because because you need for motion you
move towards an object you don't move in
the direction of like parallel to a
straight line because here you're moving
in rec till they nearly and here's a
straight line right okay and then the
issue here is that you should be moving
towards an object you can't you know
again when you move you move towards an
object direction is simply pointing or
what's the other word that I was looking
for pointing or facing and abjure you're
pointing towards an object in the
distance you say that's the direction
direction refers not to the object in
the distance but to the line that
connects the two objects whereas when
you talk about motion you're talking
about moving towards the object that's
in the distance so these are two
different concepts what is a static
concept the other one is dynamic and
this is where the problem is with the
vector the vectors talks about carrying
a point A to point B okay one has to do
with motion let's see if we can clarify
it with the next
little thing that got here yeah I'm in
focus or audible I have no idea way go
so here's a use a little video that I
made today hey I'm in focus now I don't
know what happened but yeah here's a
little video we have a box it's got
yellow on one side it's got violet on
the other it's moving okay and the guy
that's looking at it he's he's has his
back towards us he's facing the box and
I guess the question we want to answer
if the box is moving forward is it
moving forward and backward and if so
forward and backward with respect to
what well if the guy is has his back
towards us and is facing it in a
perpendicular direction okay as we would
say in ordinary speech well if he says
the box is moving forward what is he
saying he's saying he's putting his eyes
where the violet section is or his chest
or his face and he's looking forward
from there to infinity so he's looking
perpendicular to his actual line of
sight he's saying look if you put your
eyes in the violet section then the box
when it moves towards the right it's
moving forward and will move towards the
yellow area in that direction is moving
backward that's what we typically say
the box is moving forward and backward
so what are what are we saying we're
saying that we're putting our eyes or
face or in our mind if you want whatever
you in that violet box and we're looking
in that direction we call that one
forward arbitrarily and backward is
because you know the back of my head is
touching the yellow region and that's
gonna be my backward but see the guy
he's perpendicular to it so you're
saying we'll hold it if you're
perpendicular to the motion of the of
the box how can you talk about forward
and backward should the Box be moving
forward and backward parallel to you
that's what I would understand you would
understand that but you can but if I
tell someone look the box is moving
backward and forward and people would
understand it they're watching the box
they're saying okay I understand what
you're saying but it's it's wrong what
I'm saying what I'm saying is look if I
put my eyes where the violet section is
then it's moving backward and forward
but from where we stand it's not moving
backward it's forward moving sideways
you know left and right left and right
or West East West you can use other
criteria my point here is that we have
to be careful with the language because
so easy to say backward and forward and
we all think we know what we're talking
about we're using ordinary speech we're
not using scientific language okay and
let me give you another example here
you're in the South Pole okay in the
South Pole you're lost in the middle of
nowhere all you see around yourself is
ice you don't know exactly where you are
you're near the South Pole somewhere and
you take your telephone and you call
Control Center folks I'm lost I'm gonna
go forward I'm gonna walk forward what
do you think the guy understands over
the phone well he says well if he's
facing in this direction the direction
in which he's facing at that moment in
time but you still don't know what
forward is you know over the phone
because he hasn't given you a reference
point he hasn't given you that object
towards which he will be walking see if
he said instead look I don't know where
I'm at there's ice all around I'm gonna
walk in the direction of the Sun I'm
gonna walk towards the Sun okay and now
now you can understand you're saying
okay if the Sun is toilet towards his
West right now at this hour of the day
over there in Antartica then this guy's
east of the Sun he's walking towards the
Sun he's gonna walk westwards now you
have a reference point
but you can only talk about westwards
forward backward reverse side with side
words or whatever only if you give a
reference point if you don't have that
reference object you know you can say
walking forward over the phone nobody's
gonna understand what you're talking
about
I can call my wife over the phone and
say look I'm moving forward right now
well until I tell her what my four word
really means what what object I'm using
as a reference other than myself because
forward for me just means I'm going in
the face out in the in the direction in
which I'm facing but it still doesn't
give me the point of reference to which
I'm gonna be walking know it see my my
disagreement I would put north east
south and west in a different bucket
than forward left right and back okay
left right and back only needs one
object and one face of the object I say
that slowly you need what with forward
left back and right I don't need any
other objects except my face forward is
in front of my eyes left and right or to
my science and back is behind me while
with north east south and west we're
talking about with respect to the earth
so there you do need a separate object
that's why I put those two yeah but
again if you tell someone over the phone
that you're moving forwards she doesn't
have any idea what you're talking about
until you tell them that's why you don't
use the word phone no that is my point
my point that the word forward alone
without a reference point is not a
direction you need to have and you need
to have a reference point to have a
direction direction again is a concept
concept requires two objects one object
could be you for all we care
but the other has to be the target
object if you don't have that target
object just to save forward gives you
the starting point it doesn't give you
the endpoint it doesn't give you the
target point that's my argument yeah and
so what I'm saying is forward alone is
not a direction there depends on
you find direction and again and yeah
I'm gonna get that to that in a moment
here but my point is that forward alone
like saying backwards or side words only
tells you something with respect to me
but it doesn't tell you anything with
respect to the the end point that I need
for someone over the phone who's not
looking could be able to tell what what
you mean by that forward by that
backward by that side words you know I'm
just giving you a reference with respect
to me I need a second point to determine
direction I need that line and right now
I don't have the line yeah but hold on
yeah with forward for example yes if I
were to tell you over the phone there's
a box in front of me I'm gonna move
forward now you can deduce the I'm gonna
mention the box yeah but I said is in
front of me which is essentially saying
if I go forward you know you say that
you all you need to do this say I'm as
long as you use the box as a reference
yeah well we have our reference but
without that box wrote a box isn't like
the Sun where where you can see it too
you only know that it's in front of me
you don't know where it is on earth well
what do you the point here was that if
I'm saying I'm walking towards the Sun
and I'm in Antarctica right and and at
that point in time the Sun shows up on
the west or on the north or wherever
then the guy can say okay if he's
walking towards the Sun he's going he's
gonna be walking towards the north or to
the south or whatever unless I use that
Sun if I remove the Sun and I'm just
saying forward I have not told them in
which the guy has no idea of which
direction on the map I'm facing you know
I could be facing this direction in that
direction he doesn't know and I'm saying
you need that second point the target
point and that's by definition of the
formal definition remember the formal
definition here if I can find it again
where is it yeah
the formal definition right now is that
you need with reference to the point or
region toward which it is
directed because directed Direction
comes from directed you have to be
directed towards that point to that
object so you need that end point you
can't just say forward because forward
or backward gives you the starting point
it doesn't give you the target the end
point that's that's my argument yes you
need that that end point that's that's
one issue and the other one is that well
I'm gonna try to define this as best as
I can and I again I don't have the
definition in the book I don't even have
the word the word perpendicular defined
which I use to define dimension and
obviously you know you you could end up
defining a lot of these terms they're
not all included in the book but I do
include them in the website and it's
important to know that the website and
the book are complementary you know one
supports the other so you kind of need
to go to both really get a feel for some
of these things I can't I could put a
million definitions in the book either
so it wouldn't have have been very
practical but this is the definition
that I put in there let's see if you
like it and obvious you're welcome to
tear to pieces anywhere and you'll find
that in you stupid relativist calm and
that's the website and you'll see at the
bottom of the page of the old you stupid
relativist calm the sarcastic one at the
bottom you'll see the word glossary if
you touch the glossary you'll find a lot
of the keywords that i've defined on the
website okay that some of those or a lot
of those are not defined in the books
they you know you'll see that otherwise
you would have read a book that's just
got definitions and i put the first one
which I didn't like I read it today so I
didn't like it too much but I put it in
there just to be honest the mutual
facing of two objects the second one and
I put in there a line of sight between
two objects that one I think pretty much
describes in my opinion or defines what
a direction is a line of sight between
two objects you have to stretch that
string across you know the two poles
that have direction and forward just
gives you the first Pole that's fine
but you don't know you know where that
string is going why because you don't
know in what direction you're facing
until you put that other pole or
whatever you get on the other side then
now you have that line of sight you need
that and I added that direction is a
property of straight lines and edges and
the word edge is defined both in I think
it's in the book as well but for sure
it's in the website so in general terms
what am I saying the word forward is not
a direction as I hinted yesterday I had
this gut feeling but today I studied it
a little more and that's what I
concluded it is not a direction because
forward just gives me the starting point
it does not give me the end point that's
the first one and keep in mind that the
formal definition not mine but the one
that's used out there also requires a
target and I'm saying also that you need
not only the target you need the origin
and the target you need both points for
it to be a concept but for directions
that have validity you need also that
target and the word forward doesn't give
you that it doesn't give you that
endpoint and again we're talking about
scientific definitions we're talking
about definition that we can use
consistently maybe someone with a better
mind can come up with a better
definition but my point is forward I
reject as a direction and you're welcome
to argue against me on this as my son
does and you'll find these definitions
in you stupid relative is calm not in
the book